[موسيقى]
بعدين ص هلقيت في الاوروبي زي حركه 60 يوم
يعني الدكتور ما شفتوش يمكن في 60 يوم
مرتين ثلاث مرات اللي بمر علي يعني
المفروض كل يوم يجي مش كل يوم كل ثلاث
ايام يجي طمن المريض على حالته يعني يكشف
عليه يشوف ايش حالته طمن قلبه
عنها
نقص الكادر الطبي في قطاع غزه في الوقت
الحالي وناتج عن تقسيم المناطق بعض
المستشفيات او كم من المستشفيات خرج عن
الخدمه فكل المناطق اصبحت منفصله عن
الاخرى اي الكادر الطبي بعض الاحيان يكون
في مناطق ممنوع الخروج منها او الدخول
اليها او المستشفى اللي موجود انه ممنوع
حدا يصلوا فهذا هو سبب نقص الكادر غير انه
في كم كبير من ال الكوادر اللي اصيب اللي
استشهد في ايام كثيره ناتي صباحا فلا نجد
الا طبيب تخدير واحد ليغطي خمس غرف عمليات
مثلا هنا او مرات قسم العظام كله لا يوجد
استشاري واحد يتمكن من الوصول الى
المستشفى مما يعني انه خدمات
كامله تتعرض لشبه انهيار في مستشفيات ضخمه
وكما تعلمون لا يوجد الا ثلاث مستشفيات
تعمل في قطاع غزه
حاليا
ما بمرش الدكاتره فيش امكانيات
طبيه عشان انا حالتي بتحتاج كل يوم غيار
كل يوم غيار بدها يا اما حخم الجرح لانه
في عدد كبير من الجرحه فيش امكانيات طبيه
واجري بقدرش احركها بالمرا حكوي اذا طولتي
اكثر من هيك حنعمل لها بتر لانه فيش
امكانيات طبيه هذه انت بدك تطلعي لازم
تحويله برا على الدول اللي برا عشان ايش
عشان هناك امكانيات اكثر
بصتي عيني
يعني راحت وفي عندي شريه في
الر وايدي زي ما انت شايفه
هي طبعا العين خلص ما فيش لانه ما فيش
عننا هون يعني دكت العيون في المستشفى
فخربت عيني يعني وبطلت يعني محتاجه علاج
خلص خربت
كم الهائل هذا اللي موجود انه الحالات لا
يستطيع اجراء عمليات جراحيه لها مما يؤدي
الى المضاعفات والالتهابات مما يؤدي الى
البتر في الاطراف او انه المريض يفقد
حياته احنا كبشر عننا التزامات عائليه
عننا عائلات هذه العائلات تحتاج لترتيب
الاشياء اليوميه لها الطعام الشراب الغاز
الكهرباء وبالتالي هي اشياء تحتاج الطواقم
الطبيه لترتيبها لعوائل الشيء الثالث
الوضع النفسي للطواقم وهو العمل المتواصل
لما يقرب من ثلاث اشهر
ونصف فانا مش ملاقي وقت يعملو لي العمليه
يقيمو لي الشصيه هذه مع اني بعاني يعني
معاناه
كبيره فيش دكات يمروا ا شوفوا الحاله
بعتنا يعني اغلب اللي عننا التمريض بيجي
بغير لنا يعني معانه صعبه عننا واللي بدنا
اياه يعني ان احنا نطع على الخارج نتعالج
يعني حرام على المستقبل
يروح